filming uncharted was genuinely
terrifying at times for the actors
rightfully so because they wound up
bruised and cut and even whacked in the
face on occasion okay it was mostly tom
holland being injured we're taking a
look at times the actors probably wished
they'd taken a day off i don't think
that i don't think i can do that number
one sometimes video games don't
translate well to real life during fight
scenes tom holland kept getting smacked
in the teeth by the sig parvis magna
ring that was hanging around his neck
because i when i fight four times i do
this
and it kept whacking me in the teeth to
resolve this tom holland went to the
props master to get a rubber ring made
there's nothing worse than being beat up
by your own wardrobe like it really hurt
whose side is that ring on anyway number
two that feel when you get into the
movies to be an action star and are cast
as a hamburger instead
sophia ali found it pretty terrifying to
run on the high ledges and the fountain
despite being attached to wires she had
to slip as part of the filming and slide
down the car but she fell on her hip
wrong and was left with a giant bruise
it was like this big what made it so
awful was that she kept re-injuring it
it looked like raw hamburger meat not an
image we needed in our head thanks
number three maybe tom holland isn't
getting old just yet he wound up with
really bad tendonitis in his hamstring
which isn't a very cool injury that's
just from overwork but it did happen
during a sword fight apparently so it's
no scar but that's pretty cool the only
times i get hurt is when i do something
wrong he spent three days recovering but
that's about all the time he had since
he had to head to atlanta to film
spider-man the life of a celebrity is
truly agonizing number four we'll get
that high five later tati gabrielle
partially dislocated her shoulder during
a fight scene with tom holland and
didn't know it until the next day she
left set and it didn't hurt at first she
assumed because of the adrenaline rush
but a couple of hours later she found
that her shoulder really hurt and she
couldn't lift it by that night i was in
like excruciating pain and she couldn't
move or lift her shoulder at all she
came back the next day and mark
wahlberg's doctor was on set that day
and she asked if he would take a look at
her shoulder because something seemed
wrong he's like okay you dislocated your
shoulder in a strange way she's proud of
her pain i feel like it's like a badge
now high five think she's up for one yet
number five nine out of ten dentists
don't recommend using swords like
toothpicks tom holland couldn't catch a
break when it came to his teeth mark
actually hit me in the teeth
with a sword there's a moment where the
two stand back to back and are supposed
to hit a couple of guys with swords but
as mark did his back swing he
accidentally clipped tom in the teeth
but don't worry he didn't get him in the
gums and surprisingly lost no teeth in
the process it was fine i mean it wasn't
like he
cut me or anything smile you're on
camera next time don't get in the way of
my sword number six that feel when you
go into papa john's for a pizza and get
a knuckle sandwich instead the biggest
injury was my ego when i got beat up by
tati over and over and over again she's
a martial arts expert i'm not too big of
a guy to say that this girl can bust me
up the two of them really bonded on set
and she was his favorite person to work
with mark really got off easy in this
movie as he's used to playing the action
hero but now with age is playing the
older parts in fact he was originally
slated to play tom holland's role years
ago but the project never got off the
ground we think it's pretty funny that
as much as his character didn't want to
get hurt in the movie the actor himself
is one of the only leads who didn't
injure himself in some way which is
present in the story of course as sully
is claiming to nurse old injuries turns
out getting old worked in mark's favor
and he plans to do so
gracefully number seven tom's stunts are
smashing in the barcelona chase scene
tom holland vaulted over a railing and
slid down a roof he ended up smashing
his hip into the tiles and his whole hip
was black and blue for a few weeks i
walked away from every stunt but i
definitely live from a few tom and
sophia could start a club number eight
we bet tom's got great calluses from all
these stunts now tom and everyone
involved ended up injuring themselves
from hanging onto the straps during the
airplane sequence all of us tore our
hands up tom also suffered from plenty
of bangs bruises and tears due to
crashing into things sophia agrees there
was hard physical stuff some falls some
hits it was tough number nine would you
take being hit in the knees for two
million dollars how about if it happened
17 times well tom was hit by a car you
guessed it 17 times to get one shot of
course the car wasn't real but the speed
of the machine or bonnet as tom called
it moving towards him was enough to
stress out his mom who was on set that
day saying do you not think they've got
it already can't they move on he called
the scene pretty impressive a lot of fun
and very painful but very rewarding
and it wasn't all that dangerous because
they did their due diligence to make
sure the car was safe and padded we
would take being hit in the knees for 17
million dollars after hearing that
number 10. tension on set was building
after wahlberg's gift was mistaken for
something
inappropriate the filming of uncharted
was incredibly demanding for tom holland
he was going to the gym in the morning
thinking oh my god i must have torn
something in my leg and the guys told
him that he hadn't he's just getting old
the physical tension led to an awkward
moment between him and wahlberg the
previous calvin klein underwear model
gave his co-star a massage gun but tom
had never seen one like it before and
mistook it as something else entirely
something a little more in the realm of
pleasure than tension number 11 turns
out spidey powers do come in handy
sometimes tom had to do far more than
stunt work for this movie than he had to
do for any other spider-man movies
because there's no mask or cgi to hide
behind his action sequences in uncharted
are the biggest he's ever been a part of
saying the cuts and bruises and bangs he
got from dangling off of wires and
falling off of things was ridiculous
number 12 the sticker tom got was
probably a band-aid tom didn't say how
it happened but he did bang his head
pretty bad on set but he was all right i
got a sticker saying bang my head at
work today what we want to know is who
was walking around on set giving out
these stickers
number 13 it isn't an action movie if
there isn't real danger on set of course
tom narrowly avoided worse injuries when
he found himself holding on for dear
life he struggled in that airplane
sequence because he was attached to
wires but was only just holding on to
the crates so the cougar arms that were
carrying the crates did different
motions like rock back and forth or spin
well they had different speed levels
since level four didn't feel all that
different from level five tom said that
wasn't that much harder do not do level
eight that's the moment tom realized
he'd made a terrible mistake he suddenly
found himself struggling to hold on
because the faster you spin the further
you fly and your odds of letting go and
flying into a crane are pretty good he
got off lucky though and no serious
injuries were reported
even still we think tom learned a
valuable lesson you don't go straight
from easy mode to extreme mode or you'll
drop from three lives down to zero very
quickly while mark wahlberg got to sit
back and nurse fake injuries the whole
movie poor tom was doing all of the
heavy lifting and really pushing his
body to the limits do you think all that
pain was worth it to drag uncharted out
of the video game world and put it on
the big screen let us know in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things